euromaxx I lights and here's your host
megyn league welcome to our highlight so
bringing you the best picks of the week
here's a look at what's coming up
whitewater adventure a reporter got wet
at the extreme kayaking world
championships growing furniture how one
designer makes trees grow into the
shapes of chairs and tables and top chef
Alain de Roos is named world's best
female chef extreme sports have taken
off in popularity over the last few
years aside from extreme hiking and
biking and skiing there's also extreme
kayaking well here is in most extreme
sports the bigger the risk the bigger
the reward euromaxx reporter Linda
Beckett took up the challenge during the
extreme kayaking world championships in
Austria now she was coached by the best
and ended up having the ride of her life
a picture-perfect idyllic mountain
panorama this is Austria's at starbelly
look at this is really beautiful here
I'm so quiet but appearances can be
deceiving trust me this is another side
of F start this year it's home to the
extreme kayaking World Championships 175
athletes from 30 countries are competing
for the title
and Here I am everybody's looking for
the sick line which is the ideal course
through the rapids this is one of the
toughest whitewater wounds in the world
some parts are called champions killer
or go left or die who wants to volunteer
for stuff like this me but to be honest
at the moment I'm not going to if this
is a really good idea for me to try this
out I'm pretty nervous to survive this
challenge I obviously need help from the
professionals here there a command that
i strengthen my mental powers eat
healthy food and I'll need a bit of luck
too I'm the lucky charm of God almost
stopped in my GW back Deutsche Welle
that means German waves hello that must
be good omen this is the first year that
they'll be crowning a woman's world
champion in this event no ways Marian
sida is one of the top candidates
I do it because it's really fun it's a
really it's a very clear challenge to
yourself and of course we do it nice
that you feel very successful if I want
to try this out what will you tell me I
think as you go with someone that's
experienced and that can teach you the
basics because you can't go along we
want to give you that confidence and who
could be better than a three-time world
champion New Zealand Sam satin is at the
top of his game right now Sam beyond is
what will the word thing that happened
to you the closest school I've had is a
few times I've just been held underwater
for almost a minute or so and then
you're starting to wonder if this is it
but um apart from that I've just broken
my nose several times you can kind of
see it right there it's pretty probably
the most crooked nose of ever seen
nevertheless you need this adrenaline
charge I mean you want the bigger the
risk the bigger the reward kind of thing
in there feeling of adrenaline seems
that flows through your veins as I it's
very addictive how does it feel like it
feels in really similar to when you try
to land a plane it's exactly the same
feeling but you're just going down way
faster some KY could say they they don't
get any fear but I think that's wrong i
think everybody naturally heads fear but
it's about analyzing the risk and seeing
like am I going to make it and believing
in yourself and you can feel it so we're
going to go out and we're going to see
Anna tandem kayak if you've got what it
takes to potentially win the be the
queen of sick line for 2016 yeah we are
checking our gear and talking about
safety measures before we head out
obviously if you're sitting up and I'm
trying to roll us I've got my life your
whole upper body way to try and live to
try roll okay so I have to make me smoke
yeah
definitely I'm really really nervous
because i know there are some waterfalls
around the corner and we're off that
water's cold only about five degrees
Celsius we soon find out how that fields
when we do our first ask him a role now
I'm sure that it couldn't get any worse
but I'm proven wrong when we get through
the steep incline I'm going down
this was definitely the craziest but
also the best thing I haven't tried out
and I thought a roller coaster was scary
but trust me auroraco so is really
boring strong crushed it still alive
back to the competition norway's marion
see though on the first women's title he
is Sam satin out on the course he ends
up in third place overall
I'm also happy as can be this experience
was really something I might still be
telling my grandchildren about it when
I'm old and gray Berlin is awash right
now in colorful light that's because the
city is hosting two events at the moment
where multimedia artists are showing off
their brilliant creations on 190
buildings across town the Berlin
festival of lights draws millions of
people to the city every year so without
further ado let's shed a little more
light on the subject light transforms
the facade of the concert house on
Berlin John Donne marked into a stage a
humbled University building is awash
with vibrant color and Berlin's
Brandenburg Gate becomes the canvas for
a 3d video art installation the Berlin
festival of lights is a real hit with
tourists two million people reportedly
came to the event last year the way it
all fits onto Brandenburg Gate is just
fascinating it's amazing I'm so
impressed it's crazy first time in
Berlin we love it I think it's very
beautiful because there's something
going on
whole city and it's a lot of fun the
victory column is often a source of
controversy due to its military
symbolism for the artist group resorbed
that was tasked with illuminating the
monument it was a huge challenge they
decided to transform it into a symbol of
love and progress resorb have made a
name for themselves internationally with
around 100 light installations sponge
now as you bukas exciting the
opportunities you have as soon as
darkness falls this moment is a kind of
proverbial sunrise you can give people a
unique and magical feeling give this a
muggy stank on
the light installation for the victory
column came to life in this Berlin
office the group spent around three
months perfecting it before they began
they learned everything they could about
the monument and its history taking some
400 photos to capture every possible
detail jumps in Camelot corner if we
have a camera drone with rotor blades
that flew around the monument so we can
take photos from every angle that gave
us a complete picture of the object and
the space around it that's the basis we
use for animating everything else does
should non-immune come when some plus
but if that by the end once we finished
all the effects and the light effects we
use film editing software to work out
the final finished film which is then
projected onto the call time that if I
think of film of disease for the points
yet apart from Reese or some 150 artists
from Germany and abroad are taking part
in this year's festival of lights in
Berlin they're presenting everything
from glowing angels at marlena dietrich
square to a house of cards at potsdamer
platz the 126 illuminated playing cards
are designed to reawaken childhood
memories this year there's a festival of
lights Awards competition being held at
the Brandenburg Gate featuring six
finalists from six countries one of the
artists is Sylvia Isaac from Spain her
show reflects German themes like beer
gardens for me it's very special to
participate in this festival and to have
one of the finalists and also in the
monument so far monument and for its
history and on what it didn't work
this is the 11th annual light show in
berlin its organizers have presented
more than a thousand illuminations to
date and in doing so created a brand
known around the globe the festival of
lights was also seen in New York for the
first time in 2014
New York partna top of New York really
was something special and we're going to
do it again next year we keep touring
internationally this year will be in
luxembourg in december and we're in
talks with rio and many other cities the
dream of connecting berlin to the world
through light and light art is coming
true to forbidden berlin will be
presenting itself in a whole new light
until october 18th turning now to an
interesting concept for furniture design
for artist and designer Gavin Monroe
woods and groves are not only places of
inspiration they are his workshop in
fact that's where his ideas begin to
sprout literally instead of cutting down
the trees he lets his tables and chairs
grow from the roots up it's a long
complicated process but the end result
is quite unique this garden in the
British County of Derbyshire is the
heart of Gavin Monroe's craft the
designer shapes trees during their
growth to create unique pieces of
furniture some are more suitable to be a
chair back some where there's a little
bit more space like this one here this
could fill out to become a table and
yeah it's sort of looking for patterns
without sawing planks or gluing wood
Gavin harvests his tables and chairs
straight from the field it's a childhood
dream come true the first sort of seed
was sown when I was a little boy and my
mum had bonsai trees at the back yard
and one of them would overgrown looked a
little bit like a throne and it was sort
of one of those you know those images
that stick in your head and stay there
it was one of those and I don't know is
it's something I've sort of slowly been
thinking about for a while and here's
the result 400 pieces of self growing
furniture and as a trained carpenter he
knows a few tricks like using wires and
plastic frames to mold the trees into
shape he even grows mirror frames and
lampshades Willow was a particularly
good wood to work with after its
harvested the furniture needs to dry out
for around a year then Gavin gives them
the final touch in his workshop the
creations are all one-of-a-kind because
no two trees ever grow exactly the same
way it started out as a kind of art
project let's make a few things see what
we can do and it's really starting to
become an actual manufacturing process
and system that's repeatable and
scalable so it's Sam yeah it's all of
these things it's kind of art and design
and horticulture and all mixed into one
Gavin's first table was ready to harvest
in January 10 years after it was planted
but he's completely changed his methods
since then especially for chairs so
actually what we do is we now grow these
upside down so you come in here spread
out along the chair and then go off so
you have one to two to four legs this
process only takes five years depending
on the type of tree gavin and his
colleagues planted these willows in 2012
the crucial moment has arrived they're
removing the frames to see their first
upside down chair of the series
oh my god wow we really have waited
years with it that's really sturdy
compared to what I thought it was going
to be this winter now what we are going
to do is we're going to graph these
together graft everything else together
and then let it thicken so here you can
see we've already started down this side
and you can see how it's all grafted
together many pieces have already been
sold in advance the lampshades are worth
over 1,000 euros each chairs cost up to
five times as much but Galvin hopes his
production methods will gain long-term
popularity in the industry this would
allow prices to come down now we've got
the kind of basic framework of how to do
this on on mess so yes this can scale
and work anywhere where trees can grow
though all over the world so it's viable
as viable in the north of Scotland as it
is on the equator the first full-grown
designer chairs are set to be ready next
year until then Gavin Monroe will have
to fall back on more conventional
products when taking a break from work
now when you think of the best food in
the world of course France comes to mind
so it's no surprise that the world's
best chef is French Ellen doodoos was
crowned Top Chef earlier this year and
it's quite an honor that's because in
France professional cooking is a man's
world only 16 out of 609 star chefs
there are women that's less than three
percent but dirooz has two Michelin
stars and she's set to appear in the
French version of the popular reality
show Top Chef well she invited us into
her kitchen for a chat
french chef alain de hoes at work in the
paris restaurant that bears her name she
also heads a 2-star restaurant in London
davos specializes in the spicy cuisine
of southwestern france with influence
from the basque region Britain's
restaurant magazine named her the
world's best female chef for 2015
awesome yes you only that award changed
a lot in my life I had more customers
that my two restaurants and have changed
my image and my clientele session drum
set some songs Oh Sheila a composition
de votación now people come from all
over the world don't you it's a case of
life before the awards and after the
award ya bein a yahoo and I've only are
not crazy Claire helen is a
fourth-generation chef her
great-grandfather owned a 2-star
restaurant but Allen's talent was
discovered by three-star chef Alain
Ducasse who she interned with syd reach
imagine me I told me that I had what it
takes to become a chef gabroo and told
me to get started he gave me a lot of
encouragement and support so I thought
long and hard about it and then I
decided to take the challenge and she
had to work hard to get ahead in a
profession that's dominated by men there
are more than 100 3 star chefs worldwide
but only seven of them are women
including italian chef ani phyo and
spain's carmen risk aida
sivakasi dance is a very demanding
profession it's tough to combine it with
a marriage and a family you work until
late at night so you're never home to
put your children to bed or read them a
story and that would be really difficult
for a lot of women click mo famous
journalist Alex allah has written a book
about the situation of France's top
female chefs he says things are
improving but real change will take time
well ok don't all this profession has
been dominated by men for a long time
and explained that there were several
reasons for this the pots were too heavy
aura was really hot in the kitchen and
besides having a woman in the old boys
club would stir things up cumali the
gospel these days it's not enough for a
female chef to merely have talent she
has to prove that talent and then work
her way up before proof guess with us I
speak t Linda hose was the inspiration
for the tough-talking female chef in a
Disney movie how many women do you see
in this kitchen well I only me why do
you think that is well I because how
coziness a cat equator hierarchy built
upon rules return bus stupid old man
move designed to make it impossible for
women to enter this poster I know that
the screenwriters even flew to Paris for
extra insights animal as bodies with to
de comer in petite soeur men know for
weak people were coming to the kitchen
to watch my gestures kill me and ask
questions it gets Joe Mike City I don't
care whose response by twist ll but I
don't think I'm like the chef in the
film me Luca well maybe I used to be
more like her but nowadays I'm not as
tough anymore key key key assume that's
been a farmer woman with all its
advantages and disadvantages me he says
I'm untouchable for me before CCC's if I
you'll see choir one oft cited reason
for the gender imbalance among
michelin-star holders is the difference
in styles well did he drive ernest r you
have to cook in a certain way you need
technical mastery
be able to create certain subtle flavors
that appeals more to men while women
prefer the straightforward pleasure of
eating prepared a surprise Iovino SAP in
a lens case that resulted in creations
like this porcini with eel and garlic
sauce or oyster tatar with caviar
that we fight with the emotions of a
woman we have different sensibilities
than men it's something you can see and
taste okay ssss oooo
michelin-starred chef manager and mother
of two daughters a challenge that she's
mastered she's far from the only woman
in her restaurant where forty percent of
the staffer female her next goal part
from chalking up another Michelin star
is a new affordable restaurant with a
distinctly feminine touch I now we're
off to Spain southern region of
Andalusia here travellers have their
choice between visiting ancient cities
like Sevilla or cavies or taking in the
nature in one of the national parks
whatever your preferences are you're
likely to find it in this region of
Spain it's early morning in Andalusia in
southern Spain we've come here to the
Coto de tanyana National Park it's the
workplace of biologists Jose Juan chance
Posada he has the job of monitoring the
parks biodiversity the National Park is
at risk of drying out because farms have
been drawing heavily on the ground water
the area's rich flora and fauna is at
risk
well Vanessa Donna was declared a
national park in 1969 the park is very
important for bird life the region is a
wetland many migratory birds from
Northern Europe spend the winter here
and the region is famous for its diverse
ecosystems there's bog land and bush
it's even home to the links beneath it
the Iberian lynx is on the brink of
extinction today the biologist is lucky
enough to spot two of them hiding in the
undergrowth there are only a few hundred
left in portugal and spain the majority
live here at the edge of the National
Park javier eid algo is busy training at
63 he's one of Europe's oldest
professional jockeys he started riding
when he was a little boy writing is a
traditional pastime here
I serve gentlemen sports support of
kings what I think if we have a country
the traditional need a host to to move
across it
not far from the National Park is the
town of San Lucar de Barrameda it's
renowned for its historic buildings such
as the 15th century castillo de santiago
the harbor of San Lucar this is where
Christopher Columbus set out on his
third voyage to the New World today
Katharina higher has set sail from here
G finances her research about the local
whale population with whale spotting
trips getting throttled I out pilot
whales and three kinds of dolphin us
live here permanently they don't migrate
fin whales and sperm whales are visitors
here and killer whales also pass through
every year the otter haven't seen theo
turkish the whale spotting trips in the
Straits of Gibraltar last more than two
hours
one of the most interesting cities in
Andalusia is Cuddy's where's its 18th
century Cathedral and narrow alleyways
and traditional tapas bars
as darkness falls the streets of Katniss
begin to come alive with music the
region is famous for flamenco but
dancing and singing go on late into the
night and it's been that way for
generations the people of Andalusia are
very proud of their traditions
and that wraps up the show for this week
now don't forget you can always go to
our website for more information on our
show and you can also watch the reports
again we're also on periscope so check
us out there in the meantime thanks for
tuning in as always and we will see you
again real soon
you